i'm not going i never get a rental car
now anyway
well then take the ge jet the ceo
insists
they have popcorn on the plane i want to
go to there
and now for best school spirit it's liz
lemon
come up on stage liz um uh no thanks
i don't want it comes with a 50 gift
certificate
outback steakhouse i want to go to there
oh thanks oswalt oswald was just helping
me hang some pictures i live in the
basement
so i have all the nails i'm drew
sorry i smell like frosting i just
love to bake
[Music]
i want to go to there
i thought at least these dummies would
do something for me besides light a
bunch of fires i have to put out
i thought that when i turned 40. 40.
i could really drink a 40 right now
oprah this is what the inside of a
child's face looks like
oh no my humble wig is falling off
this is an exciting visit this is live
[Applause]
what the blurg oh mr geiss i'm sorry it
took so long
mr guys ah
blurg look at us we look awesome
together
yeah now i know why demi moore does this
i get that reference all right mom i'm
taking off
mom yeah i'm 20. i can't afford this
place
all right honey have a good time oh hi
i'm beth
yep that's what we look like
shut it down you are breaking union
rules
our insurance doesn't cover any of this
and you are potentially
infringing on warner brothers
intellectual property
shut this down what would it be like if
cere and sue and i were not here
take my pants off and eat chicken wings
shut it down
i mean what is it going to take to get
you out of there what do you want
i don't want to do this show anymore
shut it down what are you gonna do i'm
gonna give kathy the full soap opera
while you try to trick a lady with a
head injury
we might not be the best people but
we're not the worst graduate students
for the worst does this mean i have to
change
oh i have to go back and be the bigger
person
ah what if chris already left and i have
to go
find him it's so cold
real realizations are the worst
yes oh everything's the worst
a tiny little part of me that i hate
wants to be a princess
liz it's okay to be a human woman no
it's
not it's the worst because of society
it's lemon
how did the dentist's office go did you
meet wesley i did meet him we even went
out for coffee
yeah and
it was a disaster we were so awkward
that the waitress gave us separate
checks without asking and a priest came
over and asked us who we'd lost
but it has to work out does it
do you have your wallet back did i find
my future husband sometimes everything
is just the worst
kenneth oh shark farts i'm not making
excuses jack but
this is taken care of ah
nerds is that maroon and navy
nerds oh nerds
[Music]
nerds boy well whatever that just was
it's a deal breaker because this guy is
making you talk like a crazy person
you have sexually transmitted crazy
mouths deal breaker
my boyfriend has been acting really
weird ever since he got promoted at his
job yeah he thinks he deserves a
vajayjay upgrade he doesn't he's not tom
brady shut it down deal breaker there's
no such thing as bisexual that's just
something they invented in the 90s to
sell hair products
deal breaker only one snake in the bed
deal breaker
come on
you